what is a virus a virus is a teeny tiny
little particle right that it's smaller
than a bacteria we can't even see
viruses with normal microscopes we have
to use really blue high power
microscopes to see that a pencil is like
one millimeter in in diameter you can
fit almost a half a billion to a billion
different virus particles on the tip of
the pencil that is how small of viruses
and interestingly viruses scientists
have been studying the natural history
of viruses and they think that viruses
actually came into being they started
four billion years ago before any other
type of life ever was created so 4
million years is a really long time to
become a very perfect machine right
and so I want to also tell you that
there are millions and millions of
different viruses all over the planet
and most of these viruses do not get us
sick ok there is a virus for every type
of cell there's tons of viruses for that
get that go into bacteria there's
viruses that go into plants there's
viruses that go into all sorts of
animals but for humans we don't really
get sick by a lot of viruses there's a
small number of viruses that we have to
be careful about but overall viruses are
actually not terribly harmful for us
when we look at the numbers just right
but for the viruses that are harmful we
do have to think about things like
vaccines and other types of treatments
and other types of behaviors like the
behavior we're practicing now called
social distancing